يعني احنا خلال السنوات الماضيه تم متابعه
ملف المكاب مع عده جهات وتم
دق ناقوس الخطر
لما يرتبه تواجد واستمرار هذا المكب على
هذه البقعه من الارض
بتتبع الشاحنات القادمه من والى مكب
نفايات العبدلي وجدنا انها تحمل لوحه
تسجيل اسرائيليه معظمها ياتي من
المستوطنات المحيطه بمكب النفايات
معدوميم وكدار
حسب طريق منظمه الصحه العالميه تشمل
الصحه الجسديه والنفسيه والاجتماعيه
جسديا هم يتاثروا بالانبعاثات وبالمواد
السامه التي يتعرضون لها بشكل مستمر من
الناحيه النفسيه هم يعانون
هم يعانون من روائح كريهه على الاقل من
الروائح الكريهه
والاهم من كل هذا هم يعانون عندما يقلقون
على صحه اطفالهم الذين لا يعرفون هم نفسهم
بيجهلوا انه هذا الطفل ايش رح يصير فيه
العينات التي تم اخذها من عصاره مكب
نفايات العبدلي في منطقه ابوديس شرقي
القدس خضعت للفحص في مختبرات جامعه القدس
ابو ديس
واظهرت النتائج احتوائها على معادن ثقيله
اعلى من المعدلات المسموح بها بكثير